we just want to start the podcast by
saying that well um brennan and i
have essentially run out of things to
say and talk about because
well nothing's going on is it no i think
what's going on and we're going to make
a covet jar
anytime someone brings up covet now you
got to put a thousand dollars
one thousand dollars in the jar yeah
yeah exactly it's just because it you no
one's really living life like i can talk
about
mountain biking in my kids the good
thing about this whole tell you about
slapping your
stupid [ __ ] face well by the way it
didn't get better and you know this papa
your eyes aren't better well they're
still on me and frank make fun of you
behind your back
he goes he's like this bubba i went no
it's not that bad
no i said it's more like it's not enough
it's more like this so the problem is
it's not enough
uh you don't go too my god i gotta get
laser for this because the the blood has
gotten back now blood's quacking up
that's that's how they get you
it's a tree road and they go oh we dude
we're gonna fill her by doing this
now your nose is you know what we're
just gonna we're just gonna take it here
and then we're gonna fill the cheeks
it'll fill her they seem to look like
[ __ ] john travolta i'm gonna look
like a clown i'm gonna look like a man
clown
or a kardashian or a kardashian it's not
a bad thing that's not a bad thing
but they are setting a bad president uh
you know president
president president for uh for young
females
i would imagine it's like oh i don't
like the way i look let me just save up
money to get my
that's what face all of them do
what do you mean the amount no the
amount of plastic surgery
in this town well this is so out of
control but really
this isn't real no like it's not where
we live is not
real it's not real this place is insane
it's not real
most americans are like [ __ ] the other
day yeah human
[ __ ] most americans are like what the
[ __ ] they're like what
it's always been that way with
california it's actually why when
if you live in the middle in like middle
america you want to get your lids done
it's also why americans when when uh a
celebrity gets behind a candidate and
stumps for them
it's like tom cruise is like you know
what you guys hot it's about to get a
lot hotter
if we don't do something about climate
control this guy's going to cool the
planet everybody goes
no he's not yeah and you're an actor
shut the [ __ ] up and do what you do
yeah celebrities endorsing presidential
candidates
hurts them well why because you don't
read late to [ __ ]
somebody who made anybody 100 million
john legend
shut up dude get on the [ __ ]
keyboards and make another goddamn thing
that's what that's what
we're entertainers make me laugh correct
sing a song
you can have a point of view and put it
in your art but the minute you get out
there and start stumping man
it gets it's tough it's tough it is
it really is people are like meh i don't
know sports came back
last night sports are back yeah sports
are back
listen to me go on did you watch
baseball well no you'd be proud of me
that i'm
almost done with the last dance party
again oh but boy oh boy
but boy oh boy oh last night
jordan yep he was very good at
basketball and a fierce competitor
keep going in case you guys missed that
part the new nba street you can actually
download michael jordan if you get
enough points and your boy just got
enough points
anybody anyway um oh so sports are back
last night was the first night of
uh major league baseball and
it was very weird because they they
played in los
angeles the dodgers played the giants
and what
la did they went most places just leave
it empty seats which is weird kind of
depressing sure but l.a went nah we're
gonna do cut
outs now not only we do cutouts we're
gonna make them extremely
big so it looks so awkward i don't know
why they would do that
it's not why it's not pleasant to the
eye i was like oh well there's aliens in
the stance it looked like you like
it it was like a little girl with a big
head it was weird
just do normal size cutting oh that [ __ ]
yeah
oh i wish it looked like that it didn't
look like that it was very strange oh
it's very weird yeah that's what they
did that's very weird
uh it was depressed oh it's depressing
but at least sports came back and they
don't have to wear a mask
the manager does the rest of them really
don't well in the dugout they do but the
the dodgers best team i mean they're
they're probably uh favored to win the
championship
since the 80s they'll probably win it
finally yeah but they're [ __ ] good so
in la if you're a fan they're really
good um but it was just
it's when like there would be a pop
flyer a home run which there's a home
run
in the yankees game right off the bat
stanton hit a home run but he goes to
the crowd and she's kind of depressing
it's just depressing so you know what i
did put on the radio
put on the old radio bro that's what
cash then yeah they had a cut out of him
last night oh
man dang that's cool that's really cool
that's really cool man
damn that's cool um i like the cutouts
now
i forget what i said about them but uh
yeah it was uh
it's very strange so i put on the radio
same thing dude now
you know you don't really hear the radio
on on the you know you don't hear the
crowd yeah on the radio i play by
playing
i felt old school [ __ ] felt old school
again i stick by this i stick by this
there's not a better sport
in the world without a without fans than
the ufc
you like it better i don't mind it like
it doesn't remind you
anything for me i don't mind it when
they fight on fight island you just see
a few people
like it doesn't matter i just actually
like hearing the coaches
i like hearing that actually there's a
lot of jails there's a lot i like
hearing the impact
but i'm not like i guess i'll watch this
like baseball at first i was like i got
i was in my [ __ ] dodgers jersey all
day i was excited and it turned out like
you're not a colorado rockies fan i like
the rockies but just the dodgers
you know i like the rockies that you
know doctors grew up with the rockies
guys
oh dude they're so good but um they're
fun to watch anywhere in l.a so
you see all the [ __ ] the yankees took a
knee or i think it was the nate the
triple a team
yeah they took a knee during the
national anthem uh yankees and dodgers
but one gentleman didn't because he said
i don't know any
for anything but jesus christ but and
then they interviewed him
and he goes you know they said oh so
religious thing it's religion but i also
don't i don't
i don't stand for what the black lives
matter
movement not not that black lives don't
matter but what the organization
represents
but uh yeah so everyone took a knee
except for that dude he just it was more
of a religious thing and then
who was this guy sam the pitcher [ __ ]
rod
where's he at is there a picture oh yeah
at the top right here
it's i mean just a white dude
i just dropped my right now it's okay
games are alright yeah it's not a big
deal
james there he is it's him on triple a
team
the uh yeah the games are all right
dodgers beat the show
yankees game got rained out it's just
tough man with it like baseball the
crowd stuff but i add rain to it
it's so weird and then boxing with other
crowds terrible
i i was watching the highlights of
because basketball started their season
last night and they're they're in the
bubble
and basketball's not bad it's not bad
did you get the players on the side
and you know who's the sleeper i know i
sound like a homer the
[ __ ] nuggets man with bull bull who's
minute ball son
really do you bring up mobile play that
i think oregon is he as skinny as his
dad
oh dude and i mean he's seven something
but there's bubble seven two
he looks 40 220 pounds seven two i look
older
he let well yeah he looks he's never
been 247 years old
he played at oregon he's only 20. but he
was supposed to be a first round pick
like top
five top ten he got hurt his senior year
so he fell all the way to the second
round so the nuggets went we'll take him
dude super baller really oh he can
shoot threes dribble for seven two
dunking on everybody
he's so thin that's dead that's seven
two two twenty that's the um
god damn that's um we've seen his papa
right yeah that's [ __ ] good
that's basically uh the sudanese that's
the dinka and the new weather it's so
tall
and the the nuggets posted there's his
papa i mean he for sure gets
shorter but his uh they showed the
nuggets lineup i don't know if you can
bring it up to him go
uh nuggets line up for a scrimmage game
there i think it was a it's the tallest
lineup in nba history
everyone was huge huge
joking djokovic was our point guard
here it is the night you start with an
insanely tall lineup and if you click on
that that's it right there which one uh
that tweet right there by john hollinger
look at this do they show the heights on
there
oh they don't they're i mean it has to
be the tallest lineup of all time
god damn nuts nicole
so djokovic who is the the guard he they
put him at point guard was seven foot
bobal 7-2 he's the guard at seven foot
yeah oh joker you know djokovic's first
team all-nba dude the nuggets
i mean and then we have murray that's
been the tallest guard of all time
well it's just that that's what they did
in that game he's not really a point
guard is that him
yeah it's him super stunned he's heard
of joker
joker well the djokovic the greatest
tennis player is djokovic 2
who's um from serbia so djokovic this
guy must be also
the serbs are tall as [ __ ] we call him
the joker
he's a super baller yeah i think he beat
out lebron for
uh first team all-nba jesus lebron made
second team this year
jesus last year sorry huge too just like
big and
you know did you see lebron in the
scrimmage i mean he's getting you you
forget he's been doing for a hot second
you had a big beard gray hairs and then
his hair was like nah
just [ __ ] it how old is he he's such a
man try i mean
when he was 18 when he was 14 he was
already
uh yeah i wonder if they're gonna if he
can bring it up
lebron james goes gray lakers virtual
he's yeah he's looking out there no way
that's him
last night wow
spend too much time with your family
quarantine gave everyone gray hair
including lebron
damn how old is it lebron uh look it up
the lakers look good too man i'm excited
i'm so happy sports are back
yeah 35. he's only 35. he'll be very
great by the time he's my age he's going
to be
white dude you ever seen greg odin from
ohio state when he first got the league
them telling us that he was a teenager
they're full of [ __ ]
that is a 47 year old grown man
there he is far left some people just
look older man
but that was him in college what that's
a problem what
do greg oden uh ohio state
you're you're out of your goddamn mind
you think this kid's in high school
come on in what world in what world is
that a college student
i mean seven foot the hell out of my
face man
that's crazy isn't that crazy well
that's that's what
there is he's just got yeah he's a heavy
eyelid he's a freshman there
so no yeah he's a freshman what yep no
ohio state's standing out odin leaving
for nba draft i think he left
after his freshman sophomore here well
yeah because he has advanced there he is
he has
advanced aging diseases giantism i mean
crazy huh
wow look at him look at those [ __ ]
two oh that's a beast on the left too
um but they uh
the nba is so great because lebron
balled out last night it's just a
scrimmage because everyone
now everyone's resting like usually by
the time lebron gets the
playoffs he's so beat up because he does
everything he plays so many minutes
he's usually hurt but now he's rested
papa now he's rested
ben simmons rested he's going to be easy
35 though now we're getting into
a little different though 35 and you
know i wouldn't be surprised if lebron's
taking some
yeah will you different training
different training methods you know yeah
different training
i'm all for it so who gives a [ __ ] of
course but 35 is still 35 and it's not
26.
and you're gonna lose a stat problem he
looks good though he does
oh last night he kept through the
defense and dunked it he's so good
how many points he only played barely
but i think he had 50
how old was jordan when he retired 35 as
well
because he made his comeback there he is
yeah
i've been even younger yeah i mean he
barely played
and they're gonna pick the mvp based off
of uh
before the league shut down to
quarantine they're gonna base the mvp
off those stats
so him or uh the greek freak are gonna
win mvp
why do they call him the greek freak did
he grew up in greece yeah
but he doesn't really claim greece no
they're
just probably from what part of africa
do we know did he
immigrate obviously from his family did
yeah from somewhere in azerbaijan
i think all three of his brothers played
in the nba so
it's an athletic family have you ever
seen the greek phrase we see him yes i
have once and it's it's astonishing oh
my god see this
dude and he's 280 i mean he looks like
he's enormous
almost freak
his last name's tough yeah he's got a
long last name
i think all three of his brothers are
professionals i know his other brother
well that's done now you thought jon
jones was his family was athletic
look at that do you know what the
chances of all three of your kids make
it to the
nba i mean i don't even know the odds
look at that look how big his hands are
that ball looks like a [ __ ] dodge
ball that we throw at each other
it looks like a goddamn dodge ball oh
you do
dude look at that well you know if i was
that big i might have something to say
too
you wouldn't do [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you know
what you need to do your homework for
the quarantine when you're in
uh utah next week yeah you got to watch
the greek freak play basketball if
you're not you're doing yourself i'm
going to nervous
you're talking about of complete the his
name's the greek freak for god's sakes
he's such a [ __ ] freak
and he's soaking up that looks like a
[ __ ]
it looks like a dodge ball he's so
competitive
he is oh my god find out where in
africa's family came from
yeah in greece good lord what's weird
about the nba is
uh it just leaves a sour taste in my
mouth not to get serious but would
everything go on hong kong and china how
they won't address any of it
yeah they won't address any of it and
then you know on the nba site i tried
orton uh nuggets
on jersey and you can put any like
there's black lives matter defund the
police
you can put [ __ ] the police on the back
your jersey no you can't put
you do you know what you can't put free
hong kong
they made it unavailable you can't put
free hong kong on an mba jersey but you
can put [ __ ] police
wow big dick he's from nigeria but west
free hong kong that's that's not crazy
yes it's outrageous when someone told me
you can't do i'm like i'm definitely
gonna do it now
and they wouldn't let me do it they were
right you can't do it you can't do it i
want an old school nugget china has too
much money
they also influence the nba too much of
course everybody has
you know when you're dealing with
billions of dollars i'm sorry where's
the greek creek from when i was going my
hong kong
rent his parents are from nigeria yeah
he's born in athens greece
that's typically where you if you see
again
the in the sports team the fastest
people on the planet the most explosive
the strongest
are from the biafra coast that area
they're from
senegal they're from nigeria they're
from ghana and
i'd love to go to greece yeah greece is
amazing i've been nice to live there but
i also
been there i have been there in so long
the greece is amazing the island
sounds cool the islands are amazing i
feel like
[ __ ] you'd never the beaches are i would
never come back no [ __ ] you money you
just see me doing a
solo podcast you zoom in every now and
then yep and i would
be on like some weird island with my
family i hear you on that i really do
because look at that
okay because look at that right now
that's what i used to swear
and that's exactly what the houses are
all plaster white plaster like that
so there you go and you live and you eat
that yes and you eat the healthiest most
property is that though is that
is it expensive property no no it's not
uh no in fact sir
it's very cheap because greece had a
major crisis
financials are like shanties or are they
nice no they're beautiful
where's money car look at that water you
live in that water it's clear you get
octopus you get fish
you live you live off the water
lemons olives yeah and the water
the grease of the women attractive
they're the best looking women
and so are the men in the world let's be
fair here the men are very good
the better for the greek women are well
that's what they look like and i'm not
kidding
and i'm not joking oh well they all look
that way
go to mykonos and see because they're
all naked by the way
and they're all naked everyone's naked
because yeah because the beaches are
new because the beaches are nude sir
i'll have to get on my diet
but that is greece i mean they're you
know
helen if troy had a face they could
launch a thousand ships she started
a war with her beauty yeah i mean
they are good gorgeous we gotta go there
dude jesus christ
there you go not not uncommon
lebanon very close to greece same thing
that area
croatia is supposed to be it's like a um
same thing
hot spot same thing and it's supposed to
be fantastic
i'd love to go there amazing amazing why
did i get assassinated for being crow
cop up that one time
i don't know you might be a hero they
might be cool and crow cob would be cool
too i'm sure oh yeah i love that guy
yeah
i'll give him anything you know what
he's doing yeah
i mean people in croatia do you like
your freedom what do you want welcome to
crow cop yeah he's on the anti-terrorism
team
and just kicking butt yeah he had
something wrong with his brain or heart
though so he had to retire
but still doing the damn thing oh brian
was it tarantula still in better shape
than me
by the way o'brien was at turn tactical
and i went
shooting and there were a bunch of guys
who came up to me and i went like this i
looked at him and i went
now let me guess you guys are navy seals
and now i'll go we are actually how bad
did you want a [ __ ] video
well i wanted that and i just look at
him and i'm like
i mean frankly guys if i put you in a
movie uh
it would be too much you're two on the
nose you're too muscular
you're two and they were instructors
they were like 38
40 dogs and then i went and shot with
them would you what gun did you shoot
well i shot my nine millimeter blame and
when just with the pistol
but when you see me run i saw a video of
myself i'm prancing
i have a problem i have a problem with
movement no you don't have a problem you
have sugar in the tank
and they were all watching as i was
squeezing off my rounds
around and they were like you did good
but you know they're like you know that
was good were they shooting ar-15s they
were shooting just pistols
because they trained with pistols now
here's the problem the ar-15
i just got one now and i did too now
here's a little theme for you on your
story yeah i didn't notice when you get
ar-15
to get ammo it's a whole nother
procedure that i'm going through
okay i didn't know that because i didn't
know that you can't just buy ammo
because it's a special ammo for ar-15
here's the problem then you also have to
wait again
here's probably ar-15s you better have
earphones that are noise-cancelling if
you shoot that thing i shot it
with regular like stuff in my ears
and i was like oh i'm definitely all the
squishy ones i'm deaf
it's too loud because it has you know it
has holes in the muzzle so it stops the
recoil
it's so [ __ ] loud so i go i'd like a
sound suppressor
and they went you're in california no
silencers you're not allowed to do that
but if you're
not a sound specific silencer's
different suppressor but if you go to
texas you can do that you can do all
that yep
and you can make the mag longer you can
do it all another reason
another reason another reason i want to
protect my ears
i want i don't care how loud it is
because if someone comes into the house
it's like
you want subsonic the problem is when
you have bullet that goes too fast it
breaks the sound barrier
and it creates a it pushes all the sound
molecules and they burst
so that's part of what makes the noise
so loud there you go so you're telling
me i'm going to wake up the kids if i
fire look at that sound suppressor
wow and they're not they don't actually
don't help
they're all pretty loud they're loud as
[ __ ] even what my gun
when i was with when i was talking to my
buddy uh andy about that i go
i don't have sound surprise he goes do
you know a lot of sound suppressors when
you come in at night
the movies [ __ ] you because the movies
make it things like true which is why
in california the politicians made it
illegal because they were watching movie
movies
but they didn't realize that a sound
suppressor is just so [ __ ] loud it
just is a little less
also morons oh the movies yeah
[ __ ] guys well a lot of people who
pushed forward with gun
legislation didn't know guns they just
didn't do their home
so that was yeah but there you go
liberals guide to the deadline whenever
a gun guy until the world got set on
fire i'm like you know what i kind of
need one
yeah trump were to win again i think
ellie's gonna be on fire yeah so
yeah that's all i worry yes it's all i
worry
you've got two of those bad boys wow
there you go you got two two of them
okay so you both can go deaf
well my girl has a better shot than me
you gotta have i know about my girl's
best shot then you end
[ __ ] goes with a little help i really
think you could be competitive
so we in the car she's like you know he
oh stop stop
i don't get what you're not joining the
competitive
shooting team the girl's there the girl
the instructors there like alicia and
and megan and they're superman and and
christy
they're [ __ ] uh tony they're on a
different level superheroes they're
they're
they are legit they're really excited
they're better than the steel guys
they all look like rogue from the x-men
they're they're legit like
there you go here go to go to and that's
what they all look like but they're
legit
competitive shooters it's nuts you're
just like what the [ __ ]
competitive just doesn't do it for me
well it's a it's
just it is what it is it's a sport but
it's fascinating man some of these
some of them just like so much better
they're just they'll beat your time by
seven seconds where you're like what the
[ __ ] it's about doing it too a lot
what's that a lot of it's doing it a lot
it's you actually do it a lot yeah
that girl right there christy on the far
right is
like i think the best shooter
unbelievable like [ __ ] i
i there's a video of me going holy [ __ ]
it was so fast
i couldn't believe it i was like and
didn't miss
i it took me 14 seconds it took her
seven that's an eon i was like and then
it takes tearing how long
six yeah he's three seconds he's the
best in the world
he was the best in the world at three
gun for fifty like rogan would go brian
go i would go we all had like similar
times then he's like let me see that
[ __ ] dude even the seal guys were like
what the [ __ ] what he does like it's
what he does you better if you're in a
goddamn
yeah play that play that play this watch
this
watch how fast this is shooter ready
stand by
is she a cop never misses watch she a
cop no she's just a competitive shooter
wow
i was so astonished get off her tits
well dude it was it was ridic i
just shot it it took me 14 seconds it
took her seven well she's a pro dude
yeah she's a pro
straight up pro she's also a 10. yeah
she's also a
stone cold 10 from where i come from
that's a 10. some would say that
7 41. i'm not my head look if you look
young there
yeah i sure do that's crazy mine was
13.25 so she didn't double my time brian
it's great
are you [ __ ] kidding me this is
[ __ ]
who's the big guy talking it's kevin mac
comic i brought him there
well let me do that to us jen i'm just i
just saw it no i know
get off of her skills get off skill get
out get out of there i'm getting out i'm
getting up
get out of here jesus christ yes get out
of there yeah get out of there go there
get us out of this whole page all this
is hot chicks get us out of the page
we're out
yes oh i got a new dock for your ass
netflix just dropped it what is it it's
the mob versus new york
unless they've been watching it oh
you've been watching oh yeah and like
the rico act i remember it very well but
the
the rico act i always thought it was
because they give which it is to your
point they gave them longer sentences
yeah so you guys started snitching but
what the rico act did is
so let's say you're the head mob boss
and i'm uh i'm the underboss
and then chin's the captain and cat's a
street soldier
and we they keep catching cat and she's
running her racketeering and
you know shaking people down and they
catch her and she goes to prison for a
year
but they're like dude what the [ __ ] we
keep catching these guys we can't touch
the boss they never talk about they
never deal with it
they we can't never catch them because
they're not doing the dirt what can we
do so that this
professor i think from columbia or
cornell came up with the rico act he's
like no no
you gotta try try them as a group
so you might catch that foot soldier but
that foot soldier is getting orders
from the boss and that boss should be
responsible so he's getting orders from
somewhere
so by them coming the crime you can go
after the bot as a group now that's how
they went after the five families
that's the rico act yeah that's right
it's racketeering you guys are
organizing and trying to
[ __ ] not then they have they have a
guy on there spoiler alert with
mafia versus new york in three two one
suck it they have a guy in there who his
whole job was to bug
the mop to bug the entire mafia so their
houses their cars their phones
dude this guy had some balls because
they started on purpose messing with
this he was like he was high up in the
in the mafia they started messing with
this tv so it started flickering
they made somehow they figured out how
to make it flicker so he calls the cable
company
and they route it so when he calls it
goes to the fbi
awesome and like yep we'll have someone
there tomorrow more at 9 a.m so this
dude
doesn't know [ __ ] about cable gets the
suit comes in
and he's like trying to mess with it and
why he's doing he's he put in a bug
and then of course they stopped making
it he was all fixed the guy's like right
he said it was scary because the
the mafia dude you're scared the guy was
a killer the whole time watching him
yeah but they put the bugs in there and
then they put the bug in the head guys
house
and they were because it was hard for
them to decipher what they were saying
it's kind of muffled you know
it's this is the 80s man late 80s early
80s so it's all like
mumbled and then they could hear him you
know like oh
oh i'm like what the [ __ ] what is he
doing oh he's [ __ ] his maid
nonstop his maid nonstop yeah
jesus christ and they flipped her to be
uh uh chatty kathy
she didn't know she was stupid she's
like i keep talking to this guy jake all
the time no
jake who like this guy jake asked for
pictures and
asked about you and like and you talk to
him
yeah like no more talking to jake you
[ __ ] don't talk to jake yeah but
there's a lot of
video of him just balls deep in this
lady well
the these guys well his wife went to
like the grocery store of course yeah
but it's funny because
you know these like they're like you
know they're like square fbi guys like
what is that
yeah oh oh oh i'm like is he wrestling
they're like trying to figure out the
maid is he trying to fix the toilet
what's happening he has the maid they
figured it out
and they said one guy to listen to it
all the time that probably had to listen
to hours and hours of
tape so one guy's just like oh god here
we go again that's that brought him down
though all that
that grit that that sort of [ __ ] work
that brings you down
that detailed [ __ ] work well they got
them you know that's when they
were able to build the case because they
got them confessing of all of it
and they didn't realize how much they
controlled the unions man they
controlled
all that which runs everything they can
shut the country down that's what he
said he phone call he said with the
unions everything we have you know we
have access to three million people so
if we say
stop doing what you're doing in protest
three million people are gonna protest
in new york we have that power
yeah crazy that's amazing man and they
brought them down
i remember i remember when they set that
fulton fish market on fire
because giuliani was like i'm breaking
you guys up and they set it on fire
i remember when it's like my friend i
told you he had a restaurant
and he goes uh the garbage guys come by
and he goes you know i'm good with you
guys i'm going to shop around they go
go ahead yeah go ahead yeah he's like i
couldn't get anybody
every guy was like not my area you got
to go with those guys like i know but
they charge me goes
that's the price bro well now it can put
a jukebox so
my friend's dad jimmy burke owned a um a
bar there'd be a jukebox
and every bar there's a jukebox and at
the end of the day or at the end of the
week
a guy come in and take money out and
that'd be it
and you'd own the bar and you go hey
dude that's
it's in my bar that's my [ __ ] bar and
they'd go
oh yeah but that's our spot yeah
we don't we own that
there's so much death back then too in
the 80s like the death
well what's weird is you know the the
murder rate in new york has never been
higher until now
oh i know hey thanks to the blizzard in
1997. yeah good job de blasio you know
what's great about de blasio he goes
also
we're not going to clean up graffiti
anymore it's a it's a form of expression
cool so we're just he wants to bring no
more back to the age so no more
so no more if you paint a mural of a
giant dick
all good baby yep it's it's a freedom
especially he's literally
made this he's also associated we can't
paint over he also believes you should
tax
anybody who makes a lot of money 75 of
their income he's so [ __ ] dumb
he's so dumb that guy how do you know
look at the murder rate how do you know
i'm not doing it right i'm just not
because he's an idiot
it's up 127 the highest has been since
1997.
how do you not go man maybe we're not
doing stuff right with the defund the
police and
the moves on how quickly people start
killing each other too as soon as you
don't have law and order oh
last one then we'll move on how about he
goes you can only protest if it's for
black lives matter
any other protest you will be arrested
yeah well that's not constitutional no
it's not allowed how crazy is that
how nuts is that he's a tyrant that's
what people
he's a liberal he's a tyrant
he can say whatever you want he's did
this is this is uh not a good guy
never has been they knew when people
vote him in but new york if new york is
going to vote him in then that's what
you get
we got newsome too it's like both states
on fire
yeah what are you going to do well these
sports you've got to vote and you've got
to
educate yourself you got to vote you've
got to realize that local [ __ ]
out of either of the states or you're
going to move out of either one yeah but
then people are moving out of new york
people are moving out of california but
you want to stay and fight too because
there's stuff
worth fighting for that's the problem i
don't know so much of it is do you
do you move away and run away or do you
fight it's hard
but i think because with the fight the
the stuff you're trying to
and you know when this all the [ __ ]
starts first said i was like let's stay
and fight we may even say that to our
boy
reuben i'm like dude why don't we stand
fight he's like well because what you're
fighting for you
you know by the time the changes come
you're talking yeah it could be 20 years
the problem is that when you say you're
you can't for me
like i am a pro-choice pro-gay marriage
republican
but if you're say you're a republican
you have to be you know anti-pro-choice
you have to be you know there are a lot
of things that they stand for i don't
agree with so
yeah so so i wish that there was a party
and there is there's an independent
party or there's the libertarian party
but
i i'm socially very liberal i i just am
i'm but when it comes to fiscal things
i'm conservative when it comes to
i believe in family values i believe in
like i believe that a lot of the
problems start in the home
and you want to try to keep things you
know it's
i think a lot of it can be that i think
a lot of it is the choices you make as
an individual
so there there's it's a combination of
stuff it's so tough dude
yeah when you realize how much we're
getting taxed here and then you look
around
it's like am i attacking where's my what
you're dealing with you're dealing with
a democratic supervisor
you're dealing with a democratic super
majority so no matter what you if you
vote for anything conservative doesn't
matter
your vote doesn't count you are in the
pockets of big union in this in this
state
so you're you're not doing anything and
by the way the homeless situation has
now become
uh profitable because developers can
make a lot of money
building homeless not shelters over here
but taking prime real estate developing
it but but also what newsome does when
you know what let's put a
let's put a [ __ ] restroom where
they're setting up
so they're good there they can wash
their hands so there's no reason for
them to leave
right you know it's not now it's in my
neighborhood oh is it
bad yeah so that's what happens it's all
over my neighbor i live with it
i know them by name kind of smells like
human [ __ ] yeah it needs to be my
favorite place on earth right
chin you live grateful dead i mean it's
where you're at
it's [ __ ] walking dead
because they're dead and they're
grateful yeah they are like zombies
though
i'm not even joking they're kind of like
zombies mental health issues violent
zombies abuse
and they need help because you never get
worried for your safety djinn we don't
walk around there late at night right i
worry for their safety
these people need help yeah they walk
right into the streets people from the
traffic
they need help pulling in here today
some dude i mean they just
don't but you have to change the problem
is you have to figure out a way because
it's
how do you change the law where the
state is allowed to take somebody who's
not being a danger necessarily
against their will and put them in a
hospital put them in a treatment center
you would have to change the law at root
go vote on that right let me know how
long that
takes to pass that's the problem let me
know if you even take it up to
sacramento they're like nah dude stay
here
in venice and deal with it let me know
how long it's gonna take to clean up
venice
go to go go to events where joseph is
that's his beat as a cop go to the
tenderloin in san francisco
you have well i went to a crackhole
blocks and blocks of junkies and
the walking dead i went to a crack house
yeah and i was ms-13 you've got all
kinds of gangs he took me to krakow a
friend of
ours was like oh you wanna see what it's
like i'm like yeah it doesn't seem too
bad you just go in that room
all right i walk in this i mean it's a
crack house yeah
it's not like i was in training day but
i had no idea that stuff can be
that stuff can be avoided well what area
general don't give up
uh like glendale burbank area glendale's
getting a little dicey
burbank's c chip her bank is fine
burbank it's always
flown on the red burbank is a nice area
man shout out to jay leno
governor burbank basically i heard that
what
cops will do in burbank if they see a
homeless person is they'll pick them up
no they'll pick them up and then drop
them off like outside of the
drop them off yeah like venice or
glendale downtown yeah that's why it's
nice
it's like you know pasadena is
underrated too pasta is a good place
oh pasadena is great problem is the air
problem is in the summer
the wind when you get older blow the all
the smog
against those mountains it's nice though
so you're in this range it's pretty bad
it's underrated man i love burbank
burbank airport's my favorite oh it's
the best it's only
it's not like i always look there first
for flights and then i look at laxatives
it's a [ __ ] yeah
but you're close to lax yeah i love
like jay's gonna jay's gonna come in uh
next month him and his wife come stay
with us
okay like make sure you fly into burbank
so much easier burbank's a great airport
who put these twizzlers here
they've been here for like i eat them
non-stop
girl bro my girlfriend brought them in
huh why do you like them i don't need
them my favorite candy
but you could eat you'll get all those i
could eat that whole thing yeah
really do you you know what i ate the
other night and i
uh you need that in the sitting no
that's such a giant time i i i i could i
can eat a whole pack you know the packs
at the movie theater i'll destroy that
within the first before previews are
over
okay i need i i need to eat two at a
time oh boy
you're attainable brian is so concerned
for you i know he's a candy boy
i just have a natural shut off where i'm
just like
i see i don't have that whatever that is
it's not in me
like cars can't get fast enough food
can't get i can't get enough food coffee
can't get strong enough
it's a good thing i'm not into drugs
dude you're you're unexpectedly od
yeah definitely still you're still doing
your nicotine patches you got one in
right now brian
blood pressure blood pressure high no on
point that was
long what was that is it was that was
that from the nicotine no
they did well do they test me right when
i was doing nicotine and whiskey yeah
and coffee a ton of coffee kind of top
cut yeah it was just bad deadpool's then
they too yeah
drink drinking monsters non-stop i'll
tell you what though i rode my regular
bike my stump jumper which isn't it
e-bike today first time bro
in like two weeks cause i've been on my
e-bike oh you have so you've been riding
your e-bike up there well so i've i've
i have a yt industry bike which is a
straight e-bike
you might as well be on a motorcycle
it's cheating i really don't i could go
30 miles i don't sweat
i can go up the mountain you know it's
like you're based on a motorcycle
and then the the levo specialized like a
hybrid
it's so light and the motor is not that
powerful but it does help you
you know and then there's just a regular
bike so i'm usually on the levo 99
of the time i'll go you know 24 to 30
miles they said that's equivalent of
going like
cut cut it in half so if i if on an
e-bike go 30 miles
you're really only biking about 15 miles
still a long way still a long way but
still not
30 miles yeah but you just see a lot
more on the other bike it's funner
so today i did my regular bike dude i
get 12 miles in my legs were
shaking shake it's just not it's just
not those bikes are cheating they're
just
our men biking is my [ __ ] legs were
shaking i sent you the pictures of those
rattlesnakes dude
four of them four of them four of them
dirt noodles
turn into those dirt noodles those
serpent devils
four of them dude
[Music]
we've seen them already though right
yeah yeah yeah we saw them yeah
every day again nothing's going on so
we're going to recycle
some of our old podcasts no but i i dude
i can only post some of these snakes
today i saw two more but like how many
snakes am i gonna put yeah if
if i must be so many that's what i was
thinking i mean there must be
you know what i like when i'm on the
single track where you're in the middle
of the f
on the like trails yeah if i see bunnies
that's a good sign
honey's on around snakes so i see a lot
of bunnies a lot of lizards i'm like
that's a good thing
but if it's real quiet my god ain't good
and i take my headphones out because you
want to hear him if you hear him you
know what i'm saying you want to hear
them
but you should ride with headphones
there's no um it's it's such a crazy
that that's why you cannot have a dog
out there your dog is going to get bit
i do you cannot help me i see people in
their dogs and i'll tell them like i'm
telling you man i'm here every day
there's rattlesnakes
all over this oh and their dog's just in
the sides where they're the rabbits
hey chill you're like i'm telling you
i'm on a leash or i see this dad all the
time with his two kids i'm like dude i'm
telling you man
you can't have them on the sides no [ __ ]
no
that scares me i'm like luckily they're
not luckily they're not aggressive and
they run away but
oh no or they're not they're pretty
great or they're not i don't know who
told you that
i mean dude you you [ __ ] getting here
one day it is game on
game on game i mean especially for a kid
like if they don't see him and they you
surprising that kid's getting [ __ ] up
or a dog
think about the notes that happened to
my dog got bit right on the face
his head swelled up like that i had to
carry but he was fine
um no i mean finally he was but i had to
carry him
and i took him to the vet and they said
um we think he's gonna be okay i think
really
yeah because what's problems don't get
on the nose girl
doesn't matter frank [ __ ] was her name
she was an american bulldog i don't know
anyone who's been running
but i was thinking about the other day
how funny it would be if i got i get
covered
beat that and now you bit by rattlesnake
beef makes sense for 20. yeah
you can i would rather get coconut you
can build an immunity by that
rattlesnake i think you can build an
immunity to
if you give yourself tiny doses of the
poison i think you can like
actually build up i don't want to find
out it's not that big of a problem
no no but you know you could maybe keep
giving yourself
time people do that does herbitals do
that with cobra venom
yeah i remember i guess real stuff he
did it with a blue cry was the most
poisonous snake of all time
but those guys on that uh what was it
the house of pain was the pain
the pain showing that i was obsessed
with jesus what the [ __ ] just looking at
rattlesnake bites
wait what is that rattlesnake bites
that's disgusting
oh no yeah it's not the flesh look at
that guy's centigrade's the flesh
let me see his finger his finger looks
like this which one this one balls i
don't know
the one there's a lot of them oh that
one the
one that looks like some nuts we just
sucked that one down no no no no the
giant the
this one is nuts the one that's really
popping yeah
holy [ __ ] eggplant after you ignored a
baby rattlesnake bite well you can't
ignore it
if oh look at that guy's [ __ ] arm
if i get bit it's going to be it's going
to be here it's going to be it's
because as i'm pedaling that's a close
thing you get you're getting the
criticism i guess it just
destroys the tissue you need that serum
guy's foot down there yeah you need the
anti-venom
[ __ ] that's terrible yeah yeah
it's it's gonna take me a while it's
gonna take me at least 30 minutes to get
home if i get bit on that trail at least
but on the e-bike i get there faster
yeah hopefully i don't pass that got a
bike though they're not going to bite
you look at that guy's palm
is that his palm that's one
it's a far f uh a far left chin uh third
one just yeah
that you missed it looks like a galaxy
oh my god what's crazy
is nature lets you know how dangerous
these things are can you see me like
well of course that thing's [ __ ]
vicious they're like a cool i didn't
they're like all them have these cool
colors like they look like exotic cars
you know and then that's a rattlesnake
they have what is that no snake no it's
not is that a rattlesnake
looks like it looks like a viper what
kind of
snake is that because the uh
there are some snakes like like the
black mom of the green mama they always
say if you get bit
um just just sit down find a tree sit
down and stare
because you'll be dead soon
what oh wait
oh is he okay eleven thousand dollars
for entertainment doesn't have insurance
no the family has does not cover snake
bites way to go insurance
piece of [ __ ] it could cost anywhere
from 10 to 20 grand
little boy's okay so so what kind of
snake was that it's not saying it's a
round no i said rattler where
it doesn't look like rabbits keep going
up
yeah rattles like pygmy rattlesnake yeah
jesus
all right well yeah that rattles nothing
the
rare right because you gotta take a you
gotta melt the [ __ ] snake into the
thing what's all the writing they do on
his foot
looks like they were gonna yeah why did
they do all that right maybe to see how
much it's going how much it's expanding
or something
yeah poor little dude yeah
so cute i know at least doesn't look
that doesn't look that bad for him
though
when you have kids man oh my god i don't
take tiger hiking on this chest
no i see so many rounds no thank you you
ain't coming here no you're on another
too stressful i mean usually they feel
the ground as you walk
especially
they say that man but i've seen someone
else think so you just they don't give a
[ __ ] dude yeah they're like
i'm shunning myself yeah so like what
dude yeah this is my song
yeah what was that guy that that great
alexander the great
who [ __ ] conquered the world and he
goes up to was it seneca or he goes up
to this famous philosopher forget this
book
and he says um is there anything he
admired
the philosopher think it was seneca he
admired him so much
and he goes uh is there anything i can
do for you
and he was signing himself he said yes
you can move a little bit you're in my
son
jesus cat you have a snake tattoo
yeah i have a snake tattoo do you love
snakes uh no
badass uh no all of the men in my family
are heavily tattooed growing up and they
all had some form
of snake or dragon so i it reminds me of
home
that's fair that's cool my grandpa was
terrified of snakes and he had a big
big ass snake around a knife on his
forearm he also had a panther that's why
i got the panther my sister has snakes
too she has a medusa
tattoo so she has a bunch of snakes
all right right here she and i have like
you have something there too
i have some right here and she she has
it right here yeah she has it right here
and it's like snakes all here yeah it's
like medusa's face and then snakes
everywhere
are are the men in your family tough uh
yes yeah yeah
a lot of men in and out of prison when i
was growing up ah yeah
it's just some gangster activity and
they have tattoos
yeah a lot of times prison tats some
some prison tats or
these men uncles yeah like mostly uncles
cousins
stuff like that chin just has the one
tattoo
oh yeah are you gonna get your neck
tattoo i'm still waiting for the
the right artist i still want to get a
neck cat too what tattoo did you get
with brendan and jay in uh ireland it's
like a horseshoe oh
we said all the shows you all think yeah
let's have this horseshoe hershey a
horseshoe
why because it's lucky i don't know what
we just picked that one really didn't
represent i was like don't get up
because we were gonna get clovers
like that's not irish dude we don't do
that here we're like no what he's like
we don't do clovers
he's like that's an american thing that
you guys think we're going to do or
something
yeah we're getting a shamrock he's like
this please don't get that he's he goes
i'm not gonna do that
then he won't give chin uh the tattoo on
his neck either he was your first one
not doing your neck
really stand up guy yeah good for him
he's like you know you're not getting
any lame irish tattoo
i like this shamrock or yeah he's like
it's not happening
well it's your [ __ ] i would have
still loved it dude i would have loved
it what do you want on your goddamn neck
well i mean it's changing now that i've
had time to think about yeah
my girl got these these tattoos i put
one here my son put some on she got like
these
high tech tattoos that you the temporary
type oh yeah they last for
like a couple weeks yeah this one's been
on for i don't know what time it looks
pretty
we uh yeah it's been about a week if i
get a tattoo i'm going to get a fake one
first see what it looks like
that's the point of uh those new tattoos
so you can kind of have it as a test run
but
i put one on my girl well you got your
eyelids done shaking your tattoo so but
my girl did
uh my girl did one she went she was like
let's see how it looks here i put it
there
it's a good thing this temporary tattoo
so i was like well let's not do that
forever
because yeah chin was just a bad look
my girlfriend actually drew what i
wanted sort of kind of on my neck i mean
she could drop
decently what is it again is it a
dolphin or something that was like a
fish
then it changed something else i forgot
what it was jing kills fish dude but
then i looked at it
i took a picture of her she took a
picture i was like it looks pretty dope
why don't you get something tough like a
[ __ ] no i was the worst
i think it's the worst thing people do
with tattoos trying to look tough get a
[ __ ] um
dragon yeah like ah nah i like hearts i
like
art arty stuff nature art
get a waterfall
i would do fishing stuff for sure oh
yeah yeah
i like musical notes if you're you're a
musician that's musical notes
i think for some reason that's actually
cool no write a song
and then get those musical notes i've
seen musical notes and i've seen
microphones with the wires
too much too much i think yellow cool j
has the microphone yeah which i i just
don't
i'm not gonna get a stool and a mic
you're supposed to get tattooed quite
some time ago i was when we got the 10
million downloads i know but what did
you get
years ago i don't know dude that's for
you to figure out you know watch your
small one inside your arm
okay i can't think of a [ __ ] thing i
want
do you under the knife for your lids you
get a small lids were different
why because apparently i was going to
have to get it done
i'm not saying if you were in the if
you're in the midwest
this would never happen i was all hooded
i was going to have trouble getting
i was gonna get to a point where you
wouldn't be able to see my eyes that's
not true
and now my eyes are tight
now my eyes are tight it's weird you
still got the hoods
i got the hoods i there was this last
surgeon who said
i mean you need a brow lift dude and i
was like it ain't never happening
six months from now they [ __ ] take
your they take your
they cut you here and they pull that
[ __ ] up get the [ __ ] out of here it's
never happening
i don't i've told this story before
he got his face pulled back he goes
they take your face off but they cut
they cut
here they cut here around the ear and
then snap
that and then pull that and he was fresh
and we had a party
did i tell you guys you said his blood
or something
dude it was so juicy like he must have
just got out like the day before
yeah it was all juicy and like vaseline
here he's in a suit and everyone's like
well sir and he's like dabbing it yeah
there's blood i'm like yeah
your new face drunk girl goes the whole
party goes
richard
runs at him he's like what the [ __ ] she
jumps on him
but he he go like she's big girl he goes
oh and falls and she's falling she goes
no
grabs his ears
dude ambulance party yeah
dude you can't pull somebody's face off
i'll do i will never get you they take
your face
dude off they when you do it so for men
facelifts take 13 hours they take your
face off
and they and they have to like put it
back on they clip get that [ __ ] cut here
though so you can always tell it's going
to have scars here
every doctor will tell you this too
watch this ready like look at me
say it help a little and say you want a
facelift and then i want you to say
say how long is the how long will it
take to recover
recovery very quick for you i'd say uh
you know maybe a week you know got to
keep it down quiet and then you know
maybe
maybe a week and a half yeah we'll see
in three months
three months see in three months well my
boy richard was like you know what
i'm going to come back a day after
i i we're we're at the palms because i
would never forget that's adorable you
rented out the top floor of the palm
casino
there's all his drink he's had this like
energy drink there's all this stuff all
these big wigs there girls
drinks food and then just the sloppy hot
girl goes
richard and then i'm like oh hell yeah
oh grab his
and then [ __ ] jump jesus and puts her
legs around him jesus he's
oh he's like 60 something had a face
lift and he goes whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa and he goes to
the town two she goes no
yeah and it was awesome i got i got a
double hernia
double hernia and the doctor said to me
we're gonna scope it you'll be up and
around in four days
hey dude hey [ __ ] dude i walked like
an old man for one month
with the hernia i walked like an old man
for one month
and he he didn't cut into the muscle he
scoped it my stomach's africa never been
the same
i was so bloated and pushed because they
fill you with carbon dioxide or
something to
work it was [ __ ] horrible i was in
more pain i can't even tell you about
martin no it was awful
yeah no no no down here down here
oh the muscles between anytime you have
surgery
you're never back to what you like the
way god made you it's always a little
apparently laughs you told me uh
anesthesia is bad for you
oh awful awful for you talk to a doctor
about it it's so bad for you right you
should avoid it at all costs really it's
not natural
it's so for your body it's the drop the
trauma puts on your body
insane people die from it yeah all the
time all the time
complications with uh that with
anesthesia is
insane yeah that's why if you haven't
asked your anesthesiologist they make so
much money
but they make so much money because
their insurance because usually they're
privately insured
their insurance and each month is my one
of my best friends in denver oh yeah
rhino blacinsky's one of the top
anesthesiologists in the world and dude
his insurance is through the roof
because they die you know if something
goes they're allergic to something first
of all you shouldn't be eating too like
my anesthesiologist when i did my eyes
he called me a very nice guy
such a sweet man he's like hey just
looked at your stuff your vitals you
look like great we're gonna have a great
time tomorrow i hope
he's like just make sure you don't eat
anything until you know from from 12 on
you
any food in your stomach not even water
if you don't mind because you don't want
to be throwing that up and that can be a
problem
he talked really like that's nice such a
sweet man and i don't remember going out
i don't know you never do he just goes
he put it in and
and he goes he's counting backwards and
i was like i don't remember
i don't even think he said that you know
you put it in i was just like you're out
yeah
i remember the last surgery i got was on
my nose when i fought croat cop
and they had to have reconstructive nose
surgery dr rhino butchinsi
did uh the anesthesia dr
rhino uh no his name's ryan
o'briechinski oh right
yeah good buddy i still thought i talked
to him dan every month still jay still
works out with himself
good friend of ours yeah and then uh dr
chad who's our buddies the doctor for
the broncos did my nose
thing but i remember them sitting down
and he like right
i was so sc i hate hospital i was so
scared so nervous and so they gave me
stuff to relax me and then
when they're going like i just kept 10
backwards i think i got to
take four i got four okay backwards
though ten
nine i get to four and like all right
keep giving it to a man but i
but they said i i don't remember any of
this i started talking [ __ ] to one of
the nurses
because he had a kansas jayhawks hat on
and you know i played for the buffaloes
and we hated kansas
he's like dude you went really hard at
that nurse man i was like what
like oh dude you were tearing into about
playing for the kansas jayhawks like
i don't remember any of this yeah that's
like my friend's uh
son 15 16 year old kid comes out of
anesthesia and he's like yeah talking
he's like you know i don't give a [ __ ]
she's like what she was videotaping he
was so funny he was just dressing those
kids up to get their wisdom teeth out
have you ever seen those are so [ __ ]
funny i got picked up from the
after doing my lids and apparently i was
like this
did they give you any uh painkillers i
never took one do you still have them
i do still have them i do still have
them i got good ones
yeah i never took one painkiller me and
chin would like to see those
you like them you want to make sure that
they're they're good you guys what do
you guys like
it in i wanna make sure it's not poison
vicodin is not strong enough what do you
what do well i don't know what i have i
do have some
i have some strong [ __ ] you know what
you would like no pain have you ever
done special case spray
no wait you're you're you're you're not
i mean you me like
no no you're you're a fan of strong i
like
downers like stuff that relaxes dude
chin take it from your boy here
ketamine the spray two sprays before you
go to bed what the [ __ ] is going on i
don't know
ketamine i sprayed that's the first
track
i'm telling you look it up is that what
you do as well
dude you got some drug issues it's the
corn
nicotine whiskey coffee ketamine
what else can you trade him kratom candy
cranium
kratom you got a lot of [ __ ] going on in
your body
yeah i love kratom freedom's health
yeah it's natural yeah the dried leaf
i haven't had uh a painkiller in
years i know you had a little you had a
little addiction yeah lebron
what do you mean by problem stein kicked
the habit
what was the what were you taking
percocet name one oh really
well when i got my nose surgery my
friend oxytocin
oxycontin was like oh i'm a cool guy
and wrote me a script for like way more
than i should have had so
you know i don't i don't i know
especially back then when i was fighting
i never drank
so it was like i could have one drink
and pop a painkiller and it was like the
best feeling
yeah really well i wanted to keep that
feeling so
it just makes you feel what oh god
painkiller no it makes you feel like
like you're like like a warm hug and you
everything's great
however you keep doing it you keep doing
it you're lo your world spirals down
yeah you know
real agitated eventually and then you
start getting addicted
they mix it with acetaminophen sometimes
yeah so you can only take so many
before your liver shuts down that's
their the reason they put acetaminophen
in there yeah
it's a bad bad combination by the way i
i haven't had one like
years years it's the worst thing ever
don't ever start it's so hard to get off
of how long do you take those
me yeah probably a few years
do you take um you still you take
adderall now too take nothing
other than my blood pressure medication
and then create them once in a while
you tried um adderall i don't know i've
tried it before
yeah every day every day but small doses
that'll keep your blood pressure high
yeah that's that's an amphetamine that's
that's an upper though it's an
amphetamine salt it's not perfect
well the i did it i did a half of one
hour
remember i was like you guys i'm [ __ ]
super clear
loading it i was like i'm gonna do this
all night when i called you up for
promote it you got mad it's cocaine yeah
yeah
it felt too good i was like i can't do
this i was like yeah i feel amazing
like upper well the monofil the pilots
you know
i've taken that provision whatever i
used to i used to get it from china
well but they said fighter pilots take
to stay awake
people get this girl they get their
supplements from mexico from from
from china yeah but i just don't know
where do you think it's all coming from
i know but i'd rather go
to china a medical company that actually
does the test that's because you're a
giant [ __ ]
yes yes i don't i don't know what i'm
putting in my face i'll
buy something from the shady dark
website
in china it comes and i pop it in my me
too yeah i'm like that feels pretty
legit
maniac yup god damn it you too much
not me oh i'll get i'll get i'll look at
the back so i go cool
pop and like that's pretty legit i don't
do i've never i've just not drugs happy
i've never been the drug guys that's
good though
i'm not doing it i'm not into weed i'm
not into yeah
you're not into cocaine because you
haven't tried it yet right yeah i don't
like uppers dude don't know
here's the thing but i'd lose weight
here's the thing it's it's an upper
but then there's a point where it's just
amazingly
warm and nice but it only lasts so long
and you want to keep going and you're
going to keep going yeah
yeah and then you're like chin you know
what scary is that that's what i heard
we like uh something about hurt we like
painkillers but they they
in this thing get dark they say meth is
another
i don't even want that i was in love
with the meth addict so i can tell you
what happens yeah
yeah oh no i know you lose your teeth no
no they'll clean your house with a
toothbrush
they'll get detailed they'll they'll
organize again
you're great do you lose weight uh you
will too the name of the fat method
you're skinny i'm not gonna look
dude i get on meth i'm look like kid
rock yeah well it's gonna be sick
maybe it's not gonna be a good rock
almost like a lot of people don't
know he's so skinny probably a little
belly that doesn't look like machine gun
kelly if i can get it that doesn't go
through your it doesn't there's no
enzyme that breaks it down
it has to work its way through your body
so it'll last three days you're not
gonna sleep
that's my girl would show up and i was
like why is she so pale
and then she would sleep she would sleep
for
three days i was like i didn't
understand what was going on she's
probably clammy
you have no idea it was so bad it was it
was it's
i i i don't think they make any more of
those intervention shows
i used to love those if if you if you're
thinking about taking drugs watch
intervention make you not want to take
drugs
yeah i mean you know now opiates and
heroin and it's all that stuff it's no
joke well fentanyl
there was a girl in my acting class and
never forgot she had an accident she was
a dancer
she had a very bad accident and they put
her on morphine and
the teacher asked her something about
she said
he said if you have substance abuse
history and she said i
have to fight i i'm addicted to
to morphine to opiates basically
that's something i'll have to fight the
rest of my life yeah i remember the way
she said it i was like
wow [ __ ] well every anyone who's an
addict fighting literally every year
every morning you're talking about
i guess more opiates impossible to cut
yeah but i know for alcoholics there
there's a pill you can take where it
makes
the taste of alcohol taste like makes
you sick too makes you sick
dennis rodman's on it he was he was but
he kept doing it kept getting really
sick how old is he now
watching him on last dance was uh he's
why because he's the only guy that
doesn't look
decent yeah like has he had 60. i didn't
know he was that old oh wow
okay much older than i thought what's
funny about that
karma electro's still she looked the
best by far and she's so hot
but uh what's weird is when they show
that that documentary of all the old
players like horse grant
thick as [ __ ] yeah looks still looks
pretty good though not great
he was such a michael horace grant was a
good looking guy when he was interesting
you don't think so not at all oh you're
out of here i thought dennis rodman is
better than him bring up
young horace grant handsome as [ __ ] no
way are you crazy the names watch
and watch them have never been said
watch yes [ __ ]
why hey cat bring up him with the
glasses hold on that's right
there they're right down there see his
picture look at his face you're out of
your mind
he was he was this one dime piece yeah
dime piece
handsome as [ __ ] what do you think good
looking guy good looking dude yes i
wouldn't
say like necessarily a dime piece no you
want to go out of your way good looking
guy
very good looking guy and then the nose
i guess scotty pippin was pissed at the
documentary
furious well they made him look bad dude
well he
sat out because he wasn't getting paid
he was about yeah but you didn't get to
tell his story like it's michael jordan
these [ __ ] throwing shade at scottie
pippen i didn't think he came off as
looking back i thought he came off
the worst really he's furious with it
right furious
jordan's thick as [ __ ] too man yeah he
had that gut
he's great though rightfully so you've
seen his wife
have you seen his new wife no oof let me
see he's michael always the greatest
player of all time
of all time and they were saying you
know one of the knocks was that he never
got involved in
social issues social justice he said
republicans buy shoes too
yeah and the thing is that i i i the
reason i give him a pass is because
to be the best of all time the way he
was required all of him
literally all of him you met her in a
miami nightclub
she's a she's an 11. good for them
dude you're you're not a billionaire
with the best shoes on the planet
holla and [ __ ] don't pull a dime
piece in my hand
she's she's perfection they had kids
now all three of us kids work for jordan
now they do they all work for the jordan
his son played ball
right lower level okay well he played
division i think florida atlantic some
but
not a i mean not a prayer of talent
compared to his dad not no it's tough
dude
not going to be in the nba no oh no no
no
check out the dad jeans i feel like he
likes when your dad dress
exactly my dad if you see him every day
he'd dress like that like that i feel
like when you're
when your dad has a billion plus dollars
it would be hard to have the hunger to
make it in the nba but
steph curry greatest shooter of all time
his daddy delker he's a
baller yeah for the for the hornets was
really good
you know so there's like there's always
ken griffey jr yeah his dad was a super
baller yeah i guess he just didn't have
the but those those kids like like steph
curry clay thompson their dads played
together
so they would go on the court and shoot
with all the players all the time so
you're around
like you're a product of your
environment and you're also mimicking
whether you know it or not you're
watching perfectly well when your dad's
a great shooter and then your dad's like
do this
oh i'm gonna do this yeah and then
you're doing that when you're four he's
legit the best three-point shot
steph curry's best of all time yeah
that's incredible hands down
that's that's astonishing yeah six four
six three six four handstand went to
davidson no one's
no one really recruited him out of high
school really went to davidson
let him i think to the sweet 16 really
and then
yeah 16 there you go
his brother is a professional player too
his brother is yep another place for
portland yeah
i mean to make it in the nba is
it's impossible arguably harder than
making it in the nfl the chances are so
much less
to make it in the nba so 12 guys on the
[ __ ]
jesus and you got to take one it's not
like where everybody's getting hurt and
so like
those guys are there for a long time
everyone's first round draft picks like
if you're stick around traffic the
chance of you making the team is not
good
watching jordan do those that the
highlight just doing everything here's
my thing
i think jordan the greatest of all time
but but there's there's an argument for
lebron
if if a documentary came about lebron
right now everybody's saying the same
[ __ ]
really yeah i mean dude the bro the
stuff lebron did
like you know he beat steph curry and
the the great golden state warriors in
the finals student had
really nobody yeah there's argument
lebron's the best
there's argument there but everyone's on
jordan's not how many championships does
lebron have
uh i think three three or four well my
five
cleveland two with what two with miami
one with cleveland
two with cleveland but he's lost he's
that's three
he's lost uh a few too
yeah what i don't like is when lebron
calls himself the greatest of all time
like oh god that was weird i hate when
people do that
yeah you know he says he's better than
jordan
he well he's like he had that show on
hbo and it was like
the barbershop talk and he goes when i
when i beat
uh steph curry's team in game seven
that's when i knew i was the greatest of
all time
that's a fair argument but rather the
guy next to you say it for you even
even before you start shooting tell him
to say this but the way i look at it is
if you had a choice between kobe bryant
lebron james and michael jordan you had
you had to choose one for your team
i think you choose michael jordan no
matter what right i don't know you don't
hear a lot of great things about michael
jordan as a teammate
still made his team still made his team
better
and and hold on think about the players
he had
he had great players but hold on scotty
scotty pippin
was one of the greatest of all time
first team all decade
yeah that's yours that's your right-hand
man
horse grant pretty [ __ ] good went to
orlando oh yeah passed the ball a lot
though
started passing the ball jordan yeah
once he got knocked for not being as
good
but look when jordan left sky pip and
they went pretty fast
or whatever the [ __ ] tony was a baller
so incredible we also had phil jackson
he had phil jackson and they also had
dennis rodman yeah
best defensive player maybe dude like
don't you
look like lebron went to miami that's
just a [ __ ] show they you know that
that's what started the super teams but
when lebron was at cleveland
the knock on him they go yeah but they
had the highest payroll doesn't mean
they had the best guys
you know like like uh what's his name
kevin was
whatever you know they played different
positions
forward they were all forwards point
guard you know but lebron can
like the game's evolved where you know
these guys can bring the ball up
so so you don't know who you choose i i
think
i think lebron's a the better athlete
what we don't hear we don't hear any
grumblings of lebron right now we well
when he retires right
like you hear some players don't want to
play with them when he came to lakers a
lot of guys don't want to play with him
because
they he gets so much attention so like
nah we it's it's the lebron show
and then he also has a lot of say on who
comes on the team the
the decisions so did michael jordan
michael started kobe
like it's well documented michael jordan
kept isaiah thomas
off the dream team yeah they know for a
fact he had a conversation with coach
went
i'm down to play only five you never
forgave isaiah for not shaking his hand
no but but here's the other thing to
jordan's defense
no one on that team liked isaiah thomas
they all didn't they thought he would
[ __ ] up the vibe of the team
nobody liked him jordan he he's the only
one to
voice it but nobody liked playing with
isaac here's the thing he's an [ __ ]
here's what i always say
this is but bring this up for me because
if for the sneaker heads
complex posted this shout out to complex
they post this isaiah tom
he talks about not making things i don't
get it i was qualified i did everything
they want me to do i don't get why i
wasn't selected
so before you bring this up for stinker
heads
nike uh so people aren't getting
murdered at nike town anymore
when there's a exclusive shoe that drops
like those chunky donkeys i wore the
other day which are super exclusive
today they dropped the grateful dead
dunks they're one of my favorite shoes
they've ever done
it's a collab of the dunks which are the
hottest shoes right now and they're
grateful dead
so they they're cool they're like so
you'll see them they're i don't know
they're yeah they're so easy they're so
exotic so this morning this morning
you have to enter a a a draft pool to
get selected to even buy them
it's impossible to have these bots me
and j we call it taking an l
everybody's taking l's and then the
complex posted this
go to complex instagram they posted this
and it's a clip of isaiah but it's like
he's talking about
he you know how how you can't get the
shoes how hard they're
every time they put they keep doing
every drawing because so many people
aren't getting the shoes because these
bots
this one here uh scroll down it'll be a
grateful
dead oh there it is see the grateful
dead thing
and then there should be a video it
might be the grape so those are the
grateful dead kicks
which i'm going to get the yellow ones
but there should be
more recently go to complex yeah this
morning they posted me and jay were
laughing so hard
go to com wait complex sneakers
and then click on that the grateful dead
sign and there should be a
another page go that play the volume on
this
watch look my entry for the stinkers
draw not being selected for the 436th
time in a row nobody ever [ __ ] wins
them i know who's getting these shoes
now watch this i don't know what went
into that process
i met the criteria to be selected
but i wasn't that same time about the
olympics but that's all of us man i met
the criteria
i woke up at six a.m to win these shoes
i never get selected
ever i meet the criteria it's such a
bummer for isaiah thomas he looks like
he's hurt by
oh dude he must be really hurt well they
walked up when when the pistons walked
off and didn't shake
the bull's hands you can't do that to
michael he's never going to forgive you
never do you see all the comments why
don't even wake up for this [ __ ]
because what you know what happens to me
so that shoe that's
that grateful dead shoe or those chunky
donkeys that i was wearing
those shoes if you get them from the app
or a hundred bucks reasonable
not not cheap but reasonable yeah you
can
so what these [ __ ] business bots do
or these sneaker heads they get on there
they buy them for a hundred dollars
they'll get multiple pairs for a hundred
dollars
then you upload it to stockx or go and
you're selling it for three thousand
four thousand dollars
yeah so the markup's insane okay but the
common fan the like if you're just a
sneaker head you can't get these shoes
it's so [ __ ] up how do they have that
that's why kanye left nike
you know that no well he goes hold on
you're releasing the red october my
shoes
none of my fans can get them they're all
these sneakers like
these these business these businesses
are buying them all sell them for
five ten thousand dollars i did this so
fans like kids could
you know i want to be like jordan man i
want kids to be able to get my shoes you
make so little no he can buy him that's
one of the reasons he left wow and then
travis scott
couldn't they couldn't nike do something
about these bots hard
i don't know what you can do but then
and then travis scott you know his shoes
are
impossible to get he said the same thing
he's like dude nobody can get my [ __ ]
shoes just these rich people are getting
my shoes
that's not why i did them and that's why
kanye went to adidas
now connie like yeezys are pretty easy
to get now they're all over
the reasonable price but that's why i
went to adidas so
like you know kids could get them i
watched travis scott
on ballers the guy keeps his eyes closed
the whole time looks down like this the
whole time
yeah strange strange cat you that's
another good documentary
you're a little older for it but you'd
appreciate it what well they just they
show his come up they show him at this
music festival in his hometown of
houston
tell me about him what makes him so good
good rapper or just
i don't know he's that good of a rapper
he's just like he's he's definitely
unique
a personality he just makes no not he's
not a person you know what he just makes
good music that's really yeah it's it's
great
he's not a person that's a big deal he's
just a good musician
i think he writes and then produces his
own stuff and
he got really he got really hot on
soundcloud and then
this this this netflix uh
says look mama can fly they show him
when he's like first getting started
and they show him at like this thing in
houston and you know
like it's travis scott and there's seven
people in the crowd
nobody's listening to him and then they
brew three years later and dude
it's he's in an arena and like travis
scott in the crowd was [ __ ]
wow it's really cool that
damn really really cool
brian i don't know if you would know
this but that is kylie jenner's baby
daddy
i do know that yeah sounds like kim and
kind of getting a divorce huh
oh yeah i heard she met with divorce uh
attorneys i wonder what that looks like
because he's worth a billion she's not
struggling so it's like
i guess it's just custody the kids i
feel like they probably have a prenup
well customers if he's got mental
illness
that's a very dicey you know it's tough
it's not going to be easy on him you
worry about a guy like kanye you really
do
like you you worry about what he might
do i i don't include
the the videos and stuff i don't look at
any of it i don't it's so sad i don't
see any of it
so kim posted this i think yesterday
recently she's
she's saying that she's she wants
empathy from people because he it does
deal with bipolar disorder
so it's tough for them and the family
like so it's tough that
everyone's kind of looking at kanye as
this crazy guy but she's really dealing
with
wow yeah so she has as many as you know
kanye has bipolar disorder which he was
diagnosed a few years ago
and he was on medications decided to get
off it because he feels less creative on
it
so he says anyone who has this or has a
loved one in their life who does knows
how incredibly complicated and painful
it is to understand i've never spoken
publicly about how this has affected us
at home because i'm very protective of
our children kanye's right to privacy
when it comes to his health
but today i feel like i should comment
on it because of the stigma
misconceptions about mental health those
that understand mental illness or even
compulsive behavior know that the family
is powerless uh unless the member's
a minor people who are unaware or far
removed from this experience can be
judgmental and not understand that the
individual themselves have to engage in
the process of getting help no matter
how hard family and friends try correct
i understand kanye is subject to
christians because he's a public figure
and his actions
at times can cause strong opinion
emotions he's a brilliant but
complicated person who on top of
the pressure of being an artist like a
dumbass that would run for president
who experienced the painful loss of his
mother a steal with the pressure
annihilation
isolation is heightened by his bipolar
those who are close to county know his
heart and understand his word sometimes
do not align with his intentions
living bipolar disorder does not
diminish or invalidate his dreams
and his creative ideas no matter how big
or unattainable they may feel
that is part of his genius and we have
all what she's dealing with
yes good for her well dude imagine
that's the father of your
children she's going through a lot she
suffers with language she has
psoriasis really bad she's dealing with
this there's a lot of stuff it's not
like how much money you have you know
dealing with stuff but apparently she's
not a
[ __ ] load to get in the innocent
exonerated she seems like a pretty good
person
yeah i i appreciate her mm-hmm i really
do
yeah that's weird should we do some
current events sure
brandon talk to me about whoop i'm still
waiting for my strap
i'm still waiting for my 3.0 that is
what i said
five days of battery life oh like it's
just a little strap you wear i wanna
know about my stage sleep cycles my
stages my disturbances my efficiency of
how i sleep
i wanna know how strenuous my day is i
wanna know how how
like what goes on with my heart rate i
wanna know everything man
and that's that's what whoop does
apparently it monitors your heart rate a
hundred times
a second dude yeah you're strained how
good was your workout
everybody i know who's an athlete who
really loves it uses whoop they don't
use the other thing i'm telling you
it's cool too if you watch a lot of ufc
countdowns which i do right for research
you'll see a lot of these guys wearing
the woopstrap because i'm telling you
there's nothing like it
in the in the fitness you want to know
what your strain is what your what
training in real time is you want to
monitor your heart rate if you're part
of the thick boy bike club i'm telling
you man
you think you're burning all these
calories i mess with e-bikes
hybrid e-bikes regular bikes ain't
nothing burns more calories than my
regular bike but
i'm told on my regular e-bike i'm
burning all these calories that's not
true
and it's not true here's exactly what
you're burning when i was
on the stationary bike you tell me oh
you burned 1200 calories in an
hour i wear the whoop it's like you're
not even close to that dude
so i'm telling you it's a game changer
for me you know everyone wants to start
talk about diets and everything but once
you know exactly how many calories
you're burning during your workout if
you're getting the right
recovery if you're in the right sleep
sleep is so important because
it'll tell you in your workout it'll
tell you how much sleep to aim for so
it'll tell you like what you're what
you're deficient in how much sleep you
didn't get
and i'll tell you you should be aiming
for this the next day so
i mean that's a really important
investment yeah woop has a built-in oh
whoop has a built-in app feature that
allows you to track your strain
which is your output from training in
real time monitor your heart rate
calories burn average heart rate what
zone your heart is in
it tracks all this it's so detailed man
there's nothing like it
you put the app on your phone you
connect it to the bluetooth device
the strap around your wrist it's
waterproof you can wear in the shower
you never have to take it off
lasts for five freaking days um go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com promo code fighter use the promo
code fighter at checkout save 50
off sleep better recover faster train
smarter
smarter smaller turn boston real quick
smarter i'm gonna highlight
smarter go to harvard get your whoops
here get get your optimize your
performance with whoop
that's whoop.com promo code fighter
all right what do we got so this was
submitted by
jay mcgrew 17 on instagram
it's a snake stuck in a car that's a
boat constrictor
he's just not oh my lord he's just my
mouth like that
probably stuck and hating it is he
yawning no he's
he's probably yawning where's his teeth
at they don't it's a boa constrictor so
they have those
they have small things along the side
they don't have spanx well they don't no
they're both constrictors so he has a
bunch of little teeth
okay so when they bite you it's like all
jagged oh
someone else someone put fouchy had the
worst first pitch of all time do we have
that i have that too
i need to see said uh i was reading this
article with fauci you know he said he's
he's
when he was going through the stages
from first crisis stuff you get hate
mail
because i've never got hate my like i
have for this
you know my kids and my wife have been
you know we've had to have stricter
security
say people are mad at me because i'm
trying to and i'm just doing my best
what i know
you know being safe and people are mad i
think i'm you know trying to go against
trump and shut down
the economy they're pointing the finger
at me he's like i'm just giving you my
recommendations you guys do what you
want but don't point like what do you
want me to do man yeah i'm a disease
expert right i'm telling you what i know
right you know
i want it's a bummer let me see dr
apology here
oh oh 50 cents is way worse
yeah ah
it's tough if you've never done it man
well you do it before
you do oh yeah that's not your first
pitch but then it's like you know your
nerves and stuff is there's no one
i would love to tell you i would love to
try it you know the joke here a lot of
people were saying obviously
like he was social distancing the ball
from home plate all right
all right back to this so the other day
in france there was a huge apartment
fire and there were two boys
stuck in their uh apartment unit which
was on the third floor
a bunch of neighbors saw them kind of
waving out the window
and they couldn't get into the apartment
building so the little boys
both jumped out one of the little boys
were three years old the other one was
10.
both of those boys ended up getting
caught and they are perfectly fine
they're just in the hospital now to make
sure that the smoke didn't damage their
lives jesus christ
yeah the neighbors caught them
dude this is 33 feet up oh my little boy
please
look at this ah [ __ ] they caught him
perfectly caught him
now they're going to catch the bigger
one yeah come on the 10 year old's gonna
be a lot heavier mm-hmm
[Applause]
this is so [ __ ] scary
oh my child they caught him they're both
okay
how awesome is that where's the sound
france [ __ ]
people coming together oh [ __ ] so
stressful
well you you realize how [ __ ] serious
fires are did anyone die in the fire
no luckily nobody died jesus christ
what a badass ten year old brother
though to get rid of that brother
not panic yeah good boy jesus christ man
that made me sweat that was very high
can't wait to see my kids well this is a
photo that was going viral there was a
woman protesting in portland oregon
and a photographer captured this photo
she was wearing a face mask
and she was just naked spreading them to
the police officers
okay anything from the front or
not just the back it's a nice shotgun
it's actually
bad looking cool picture this is
portland
yeah what a [ __ ] joe it just reminds me
of that lady twerking
in front of the police she was cooler
she was cool awesome
all right i bet the cops like about time
when you're a little fun around here
yeah i mean they're just like god damn
it then did they beat her senseless or
what
uh no update on that i hope not
peaceful protests with their titties out
top's probably stoked
yeah passive resistance tough to be
tough to be a cop right now
one time we're good people mm-hmm 99
good people
tough to be very tough very tough job
toughest job in the world i'd say right
now mm-hmm
one of the toughest the hong kong
workers say hold my nike shoe
it's tough over here yeah
yeah okay i've seen the video on that by
the way
and put them in trains
the chinese government is exactly yeah
what concentration came out right
chinese government isn't exactly about
human rights a lot of times
and they do whatever they want and
there's no recourse because there's no
press
so you do it you can't begin so when you
allow that's called tyranny whenever you
allow a government to have that kind of
power over you
or any kind of power people want power
over other people we live in a time
where there are a lot of things that can
that can take your livelihood away
you think america has problems dude but
we live in a time now where
there's not a storm they don't cover
enough you think america has problems
please look up china hong kong oh it's
nuts oh it's i'm glad you're so
it's so into this you understand oh my
god
but i still will i still rock nikes
don't i
okay and buy questionable pills you're
talking about it from the chinese you're
talking about it
yeah i tried buying a free hong kong
t-shirt they weren't letting me buy it
the nba went let me make the jersey but
i can put [ __ ] the police on there how
crazy is that
[ __ ] the police i didn't put [ __ ] the
police out there damn
they put [ __ ] until you need them until
you need them the cops
till you need them everybody needs the
cops
yeah until you need them so
okay it's like all my friends who were
anti-gun and when all the black lives
matter protests were going on
i got a lot of calls from people asking
me if
i had a gun they could borrow dude wait
wait till i was like wait
wait if trump wins again in november
you're gonna want guns dude you think we
have problems now the [ __ ] wins
in november
well hopefully we'll be under control
hopefully we'll have a vaccine
hopefully people go back to work
hopefully hopefully but it's not even
about covert anymore
you know it's gonna be problems dude if
the economy starts doing well again
people there won't be problems
remember that minority unemployment
black unemployment was the lowest it'd
been in 50 years correct
so there were a lot of there were a lot
of positives about the economy
that kept people you know when you have
a job and you have dignity and you have
money you have bills to pay and you're
not starving
you have money to pay your bills and
your kids can go to you know baseball
that that's that goes a long way and
keeping
or that cop who you know obviously
should go to [ __ ] prison for the rest
of his life who
killed uh george floyd you know
they have a bunch more charges
especially taxes him and his wife
attacked so he's going to go away but
if the charges aren't what people expect
it's he's not gonna first degree murder
ain't gonna happen
it's not the way it's gonna work with
cop killing people he's gonna get second
degree
so that could make people upset again
all this stuff cannot you have problems
man
you're gonna want guns especially if
corona is still going on
then trump wins it's scary
oh it keeps him up at night papa
what's next all right i don't know if
this is more positive but
you guys have seen this already mike
tyson and roy jones jr they're actually
they're going to box each other in an
eight-round exhibition fight
it's pretty cool and apparently
according to andy foster
he's saying that they both agree not to
try to knock each other out
but i mean can you imagine these two
going at it and not trying to like
actually
one-up each other i have no idea what's
going to happen i i i literally i don't
know
i don't know it's pretty crazy right at
least they're both
professionals and they're sort of the
same age um
i don't know horrified sparring match i
guess yeah but i mean
if nobody's gonna get knocked out i
guess what i mean i guess i'll watch
imagine you were
to like uh fight someone in an
exhibition match i'm sure if someone
like threw a harder punch you're gonna
try to throw a harder punch and it'll
just go crazy right yeah yeah yeah
you guys like that tyson is way more
chill these days don't they
oh man i saw him in a uh talking about
the fights he's just he goes like this
inside of me that has his ego the side
of me this not he hasn't watched that
clip or no i believe it i mean roy jones
last time
you know he got dealt with in russian he
did
that's his last fight he got knocked out
and then then
following week was on a broadcast on hbo
it's like what are you doing
let me play this trailer for you real
quick we're not born to be humble
we want to be humble and let you know
[Applause]
his thighs are huge his arms are huge
his neck is huge so it's like it's very
risky yes
but guys in control of the ball because
i was beating everybody in every weekly
as i was in
what's she going to do it's like david
and goliath
he's a giant monster we know and my
eagles
i mean i'm saying you think you fly you
ain't [ __ ] look
the ammo you're getting here kick your
ass you better get on top of your game
you want to get em back
in front of these people and i'm little
david who
on the head of my side is definitely
more talented
way more time
[Music]
holy [ __ ] i'm kind of excited i have no
desire to watch it i do
tyson's still strong enough to knock you
[ __ ] to death so
i definitely want to watch it i think i
think it'll be a [ __ ] show
i think people would be really
disappointed it's just like bad would
you pay to watch a sparring match
and they both don't want to embarrass
you how much would you pay for this one
is it just pay for not what if it's not
the sparring match what if it really
does either one's going to sign up to
and
and the other one's going to allow them
knock them out it's not going to happen
that's why that's why they chose this
this opponent so they just
said the deal is don't knock each other
out and they said they wouldn't they're
also they're both
54 years old dude 51 534 i just i
have no desire to see it man i kind of
do
i kind of do too would you pay 60 bucks
for it though 60 i'm not saying that's
how much it is i'm just wondering that's
how pay-per-views are like 60-ish
it's a larger question yeah i feel like
they should pay me it'd be fun to just
do it it's a good get-together as long
as they don't try to kill each other
then fine listen during quarantine i
i'll watch two praying mantis go at it
so i'll i mean i'll probably pay for it
i'll do it gotta do it
all right guys i'm like filming at the
mouth for it though
um this is a surprise taylor swift
suddenly
without any announcements ahead of time
released an album yesterday
last night i had no idea yeah you love
her i used to love her a lot but then
she got too poppy yeah a little too
poppy thick no no too poppy okay too
thick
she was like normal she was like super
skinny like some real skinny well she
was really really really skinny before
but then
curves but yeah so it's it's a part it's
apparently like more like
pop no it's more like a folk folk-ish or
have you listened to that darker or no i
listen to one song
yeah but there is a little bit of pop in
there but it's still more like you know
deeper
and is it critically acclaimed so far
everyone sounds really good taylor
schwiff is
massive uh yeah she's yes dude well
she didn't do any kind of like you know
like marketing it's just boom she put it
out there
her fan base is so strong people can do
that yeah yeah good for her
all right um let's see this okay this is
kind of dumb but i thought this was
interesting i didn't know this about
avocados you know your avocados turn
brown right away
yeah there's different techniques and
stuff so check this one out
let me refresh it
you guys love avocados right mm-hmm love
them all right
i like that because it will be my
greatest contribution
to tick-tock are you ready it's not a
dance
it's not a perfect lip sync it's not
the words popping up that took forever
just give it to us
how to save half of an avocado okay
water who only uses half though when you
cut one okay
so that's it you just put a little bit
of water and then put it on
no that's cool yeah that's cool that's
pretty cool [ __ ] a
i actually like knowing that i like you
know how i don't actually really like
knowing do you ever use just the half i
sure do
i use a half oh eat a whole avocado wow
giant man though every time you need a
big old avocado in your tummy i like
yeah
last one you guys talked about this on
monday
so the new york times saying i mean the
headline is pretty crazy right
it says off-world vehicles not made on
this earth
that's what they're saying the pentagon
is saying right
so i looked it up and apparently the
pentagon
uh hired a subcontractor consultant
who's an astrophysicist and he's the one
that said that some of the materials
that the pentagon
apparently has in their possession he
himself doesn't believe they're from
this
earth so it could be from something else
they're saying uh russians rogan had a
guy in a show
you know who's balls deep in this and
russians got really back in the day got
really into it and had
when they would see when these ufos they
would send their fighter pilots out
but they couldn't keep up yeah all they
want is the technology
they want the technology to [ __ ] with
everybody so russian
so the question is is if other countries
have advanced their technology so far
ahead of
us that we can't tell in other words it
could be other worlds
yeah they're also they're trying chinese
or russian
yeah yeah so sure they don't know it's
just that of chinese yeah
who knows who knows yeah and did you uh
have did you have you heard that expert
on rogan talking about
by the ufo expert and he was saying they
you know one they would go around where
we'd have you know nuclear bombs and
stuff they'd go around russia with
nuclear bombs
and they you know they they felt like
they were going there to see what we had
and then they would take off have you
guys ever seen anything crazy like that
never never a ufo yeah like you what you
thought was a ufo i went shut up about
it
no i'd be a [ __ ] blabber mouth oh
we'd both you did the
i'd be like i saw you don't kill us i
mean yeah i'd be telling you
have i ever not talked about everything
that happens with me my lids
my testosterone a ufo i try to be you
know if brian's like you know i think
now's the time
my friends know everything about me i'm
not good at everyone knows everything
about you yeah
i don't think why keep secrets why i
just would rather live a life where
people know
everything about me i definitely believe
there's something going on you know so i
was driving back from
arizona from lake havasu to california
how long ago
this is i don't know
just take a look 10 years ago so me and
my friend brian we're driving by and
we're
we're on the 40 i think it was uh and
then we saw we pulled over because we
saw lights
and apparently there's supposed to be a
military base somewhere around there we
saw
three lights go up and then move
like like this and then
it was just like either technology that
we just couldn't understand or who knows
we both saw it together drones moved
like that but it was so far
and so like bright and it was moving so
fast and it's stopping they don't have
those lights like that
there's a homeless guy outside of my
thing and he goes oh no
and he had a he goes this is something i
go what he got a squash
and he cut out eyes oh senator rubio
rubio
i would say that frankly this is some
from outside this planet that might
actually be better than the fact we've
seen some technology leap on behalf of
the chinese or russians
he's hoping it would he would rather
have it be from another planet than
chinese or russians having that
technology
yeah the chinese i don't think it is
though if you gave north korea
this technology we're [ __ ] yeah i don't
think the chinese and the russians are
there
chinese are pretty advanced yeah but the
americans are pretty advanced too
and all the countries are very secretive
about what they have so for sure
we'll see we don't hear anything out of
russia they just [ __ ] with all our stuff
yeah russia doesn't have a lot of
innovation technology well in space not
really
they're military's really not [ __ ]
either comparison if you hear like
actual music you don't have the
instructor they don't have the chinese
chinese problem we went to well if when
we eventually do which i think we will
go to war with china
i do think we're going to they're a
problem right now they don't have
they're not in our
they don't have our technology but china
china china could be no china does not
military wise
they'll have the same technology as us
they never really needed it they haven't
until very recently they didn't put a
lot of resources into their military
because it was all about economics you
know for them
um they never never really that word
wars would be so different now too right
like
it's not like you know nobody wants to
go to war because there's no profit in
it
people go to war because there's a
prophet but to go into war
but now now it's people should take
business from china and war zones would
be like you go to take over land that
doesn't really how the economy works
anymore it's such a global marketplace
with the trademark in china yeah there's
a lot of money in that bubble
i know but what i'm saying is that you
don't need to go into another country to
take it over
you can own africa without using
weaponry
and they can own and they do own a lot
of the resources in africa
i know with china do you see what you
see trump shut down the
chinese uh uh
what what do you call it embassy in
consulate yeah did you see what happened
no so wrote uh drogan trump goes well
we're not gonna have that there we
you know we don't want that in in our in
our nation so they shut down the chinese
embassy
well all of a sudden they see smoke come
on empty like that oh that's right
they're burning paper yeah but this this
yeah that was that was north korea
though was that china
no china oh and then china
they we have in in the embassy you have
state secrets
and you have mechanisms to burn all that
crazy cia does that
every american embassy has shredders and
incinerators trying to keep getting
frisky you want to
call up the navy you want to rile the
seals up
you want to rile ourselves up to see you
these boys are bored
like we are they're bored and they're
looking for they're looking
they're looking for some action yeah but
they're bored
yeah there ain't no chinese like a navy
seal now
now we got to wrap this up pretty soon
no i want to talk about navy
invading china i want you to miss your
flight let's talk about
i gotta go see my children i haven't
seen them haven't held them are they in
a month
and are they flying with you to utah no
they're they're there no they're already
in st george
is saint george no my parents lives in
st georgia
mormon you want a k95 on the airplane
what you want to mask you want a good
master no he has it but
he has to answer about uh by alex now oh
[ __ ] he's good oh no
i mean we don't know about this damn
virus enough though ah listen
we know enough second time but if you
want masks we don't have stats okay but
i'm never
no i i'll wear a mask out of courtesy
for my fellow
passengers but i'm just saying if you
want you want to cool corona stat before
we go
what's that no you want you want cool
corona snap before we go so we're
testing america has done more tests than
any other nation by far
50 million people are tested the cdc
count said they estimate even with our
testing
they think it's somewhere between it's a
huge number 25
to 40 million people have corona which
would put the death
the chance of dying from corona at any
age
your chances if you have a 99.9 ready
99.93 chance to survive in cobit at any
age now
so and yet let's keep everything shut
down
well it's all political now it's always
seals and russia and baby seals in china
go
what's your ignorance and fear yeah you
just hit me with that stat
and yet we're all [ __ ] shut down
still okay
i don't get it politically did you get
the article i said yesterday yeah cdc
could not kid should be in school she
said kids should be in school
and my kids i got to donate to the jar
now [ __ ] off donate to the jar
all right i brought it up i've i've
talked to we're on our face we've
already said it uh
calen's gonna be gone all next week so i
gotta figure out what we're gonna do for
finding the kid next well i'm gonna try
to fly back wednesday
if i have to okay we'll figure i'll do
whatever i have mark sanchez coming in
hopefully joe coy answers the bell there
you go
we'll figure it out is that it that's it
that's it how fun you talk dude
that's the final kid route yeah